INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So in today's video,
we are going to dive
into EC2 instances.
This is probably the most
important single topic
in this course.
I know we introduced
it right away.
And that's because
we end up using it
almost every day for this.
I think I'll just lie
myself, by the way,
so we can start to even look
at this directly right now.
But to give a short summary
on what EC2 instances are,
the easiest way
to describe it is,
it is a computer in the cloud.
So EC2 stands for
Easy Compute Cloud.
That's the acronym.
It was the founding principle,
I would say, of AWS.
And honestly, most
of cloud computing
is this idea that at
the drop of a hat,
I can spin up a new computer
or any number of new computers
in the cloud.
So all of a sudden, I go
from my single machine having
whatever resources or cost me
however much to-- instantly,
I can have as many
computers as I want.
Really think about the
power of that as well, too.
I mean, for example, I have
plenty of students ask me
and other people ask me, what
kind of computer should I buy?
My answer has changed
as I've started to use
cloud computing more and more.
The answer is,
honestly, whatever
you can use to get to a
cloud resource, great.
You can pull up an iPad.
Use that.
Honestly, you could
do that on your phone
for that matter, but
a terrible experience.
But you really don't
need anything special
because even if I have a
cheap, crappy computer,
it doesn't do that much.
I can spin up a
supercomputer at, again,
a click of a button, as
we'll see here pretty soon,
and immediately have all
the power at my fingertips.
Now, there are some
quirks and some ways
that I'll have to leverage
that or some creative ways I'll
have to leverage that
and use those resources.
But the important detail
is we can all basically
get onto a shared platform.
And that'll also actually
make this class a lot easier
because some of you are going
to be on Mac, some of you
are on Windows, or
any other computer.
And there are subtle differences
in the way each of them
do different things.
But once we get
through this process
of connecting to
an EC2 instance,
we'll all be on the
exact same platform.
So again, it
dramatically reduces
the technical difficulties
or complexities
of those sorts of tasks.
So keep that in mind
throughout this.
If you run into issues
getting connected to this,
don't put it off of
like, OK, well, I'll
figure it out down the line.
Truly, everything we're going to
do is building on EC2 instances.
And they're not that complex.
They can have some quirks
in the setup and spin up.
But functionally, it's just
a couple of button clicks
to get it going.
So it's more important that you
understand why we're selecting,
what we're selecting.
And that, again, you can
actually get connected.
If you can't get connected,
please reach out to me,
come to office hours, or
just shoot me a message.
And we'll figure it out or
debug the issue at hand.
So with that, I'm
assuming, again,
you have logged into
your AWS account, right?
You're in here.
You're in your environment.
We've selected a region.
It doesn't matter
what region, but pick
whichever one you want to or
something close enough to you.
So I'm in this US
West 2 Oregon region.
And all you have to
do is-- if it shows up
here as recently visited,
which probably does it
for you if you haven't been
there before, you can click it.
Otherwise, I just tend to
use the search bar, type EC2,
click that link, and
you'll be into it.
So this page is the
dashboard for EC2 instances.
We have a bunch of
options on the side
that we have no idea
what they mean yet.
We got all these
buttons and links here.
There is this
bright orange button
that says Launch Instance.
And surprise, we're going
to launch the instance.
Now, if that word
doesn't make sense
to either the instance,
what we're saying here,
whenever I say spin up an
instance, create a new instance,
we're creating an instance
of a computer in the cloud.
So we're creating this--
sorry, if there's a
little hiccup there.
We're creating another
computer in the cloud,
and that is an
instance of a computer.
So that's why we use
that sort of verbiage.
So at the high level-- and
this is really the page
that we're going to go through.
We're just going
to basically learn
what all these buttons mean
so we know what to select.
And then you can see
the bottom right here,
if I slide myself out
of the way even more
and you can see
this on your screen,
you'll see that we have
this Launch Instance button.
So that's really all we're doing
is going through these setup
steps.
One other important thing
to note, these steps
can be done on the terminal.
And we'll talk about what the
terminal is in a little bit.
But basically,
everything you do in--
or on the AWS console
here on this page
can be done in code as well,
which is a really powerful tool
because I can start to learn.
And we'll learn
this in a few weeks.
I could spin up an EC2
instance from my code.
So I could say, well, maybe
I run this chunk of code
that does x, y, and z.
And then I need to have another
computer run it so I'm not
eating at my processor.
I could set it up such that
I run the chunk of code
to set it up, spin up the
EC2 instance in my code,
pass off information to that
EC2 instance, and then go on
and execute that.
So really, really powerful
tool we'll have here.
But either way, first step,
the process is just to name it.
So I'm just going to
call mine a Test Server.
I'm just doing that so
I know which one I've
created so I can delete
it, that it's not
doing anything important.
But you can name it
whatever you'd like.
It is important to
note as well, too,
and we'll talk about this
throughout as we go through,
what is at the free tier or not.
So again, this can cost and this
can actually cost a lot of money
if we don't pay attention
to what we're doing.
If we pay attention
to what we're doing,
it'll be free or
so close to free.
That is irrelevant.
And so just follow along here.
Make sure to reference back
to this video if necessary.
I'll try to keep this
video short enough
so that you can reference back
and scroll through quickly.
But fingers crossed, I'm
never good at talking quickly
or getting through
content quickly.
So we've named it.
Now we've got to jump into
the application and OS images.
So this is basically our choice
now of, when you go to the store
and you're like, do I want
to buy a Windows or a Mac?
This is exactly the same idea
here is, which operating system
do I want to run my computer?
We have a bunch of options.
You can see Mac OS, and
you can see windows.
Both of these have a premium
associated with them.
So if I click Mac
OS, there does not
exist a free tier
associated with Mac OS.
There does not exist--
or actually, I lied.
There's a free tier
associated with Windows
but not one with Mac OS.
And you can see, I'm looking
right here in this top right,
where it says free
tier eligible.
But primarily, you'll
pay a slight premium
on Mac and Windows
images and a few others
as well, or operating systems,
because they have basically
licensing fees
associated with them.
Everything else that's
not Windows or Mac
here is some other
flavor of Linux.
So Linux is a very widely
available operating system.
It's open source.
So anybody can go and
download the original code
and build, often called,
different flavors
or distributions of Linux.
They have different features,
capabilities, targeted markets.
Some are supported
companies that
are-- companies that are
profit-making companies that
are trying to provide a resource
through a better operating
system.
Some are open-source projects.
So all sorts of flexibility.
You'll see Amazon has
their own flavor of Linux.
So the Amazon Linux
is an option as well.
Functionally, they
share a lot of the same,
I would say, commands
and arguments with them.
But again, you'll know
the context of which
one is appropriate when.
We're going to exclusively use
Ubuntu in this class, I'd say.
I mean, I don't know
for sure, but my guess
is it'd be probably the most
popular distribution of Linux.
So if you ever just go to
ubuntu.com, you can come here.
Sure, I'll accept cookies here.
This is the main page of Ubuntu.
And you can see
here, you can just
click Download Now to
download the operating system.
You could download
it to your computer
and install it on
your personal computer
and turn your computer
into a Linux machine.
All sorts of things you can do.
The nice thing with Ubuntu
is it is very user friendly.
So let me see if I can
find an image or just
a picture of the Ubuntu desktop.
So I just go to images here.
So Yeah, this is what the--
if you were to use
a user interface
or pull this up on
your monitor, this
is exactly what it
would look like.
So it has Firefox.
You can download Chrome for it.
They have an App Store
files that you can explore.
It's great.
It looks exactly like any
other modern operating system.
If you're a gamer, you can
download Steam on there.
There are certain games that
do play on Linux machines.
So there's all sorts of
flexibility and capability
with this.
The real benefit
to us using Ubuntu
is that, really any
Linux-based operating system,
is that they are open source.
Or at least some of
them are open source,
meaning that if we run
into issues or errors,
there's probably somebody online
that has dug deep into this code
and found some issue or error
with it and has advice on it
or can provide advice on it
versus if, all of a sudden,
Windows is crashing,
there's a level of repairing
on the computer or
maintenance on the computer
that we can't really
do, we can't manage.
It is private source
code for Microsoft.
Another thing that I've used
this a ton for or Ubuntu,
specifically, is, if I get into
a situation where I'm working
on some project and I'm so knee
deep in errors that I cannot
figure out what's going on--
I mean, it's just all broken.
Turning it off and back on
again isn't solving my problems,
and the computer's
just bogged down--
I can take the extreme approach
of deleting my entire operating
system and reinstalling it.
It's very common to download
Ubuntu onto just a flash drive,
like an 8 gig or a
16-gig flash drive.
Plug it into your computer and
just boot from the flash drive
directly, meaning that,
again, I can completely
delete the operating system,
everything associated with it,
and reinstall it in
probably sub-one hour
and have a brand-new,
fresh computer again.
It's a great way to actually
also reuse an old computer.
So if I have an old laptop
that is starting to fade,
the battery life
isn't that great,
I can wipe the operating system,
get Windows or whatever off
of it, and install Ubuntu or
some other flavor of Linux
on there.
And oftentimes, because
Linux is-- or Ubuntu
is so lightweight,
it'll actually
kind of extend the battery
life because it's not as power
hungry.
It makes it much more usable and
gives it another lease on life.
So I can't speak more
highly enough of Ubuntu
or really of Linux-based
operating systems.
They make software
development, data science,
work so much easier.
So if you are in that space
or you're interested at all,
I highly encourage
you to check this out.
Or you can come
talk to me, and I'll
help you think
through what it could
look like to install this
on your own personal machine
if you want to.
But for us, it's even easier.
Again, we're all just going
to use it in the cloud.
So we don't even have
to think about what
it means to install it.
They're going to-- or the AWS is
going to handle all and install
for it.
So I'll select Ubuntu
here, and that is me
selecting the operating system.
And then below here, I can
select the machine image.
What this basically
means is this image
is what software is
default installed on there.
So you can see,
for example, I have
different versions of Ubuntu.
I have 24.04, 22.04, both of
these being free tier eligible.
These other ones, if they don't
say they're free tier eligible,
then they're not.
That means that even
with the cheapest one
or with the smallest
instance, you're
still going to pay something.
It might not be a lot, but
it's just worth noting.
This can be really
helpful, though.
So for example here, I've
used images like this
before, where I'm doing
specific deep-learning
or machine-learning
research or work,
and I need to have
GPU drivers installed.
PyTorch is a library
in Python for doing
a lot of deep-learning work.
And I can just
click this button.
And then when I go to
create the EC2 instance,
it'll have pre-installed
all this stuff.
I don't have to worry about it.
I don't have to go through any
menus or anything like that.
So it can dramatically
reduce the effort.
You can actually
also come in here
and browse more
AMIs, machine images.
And this is basically
a public marketplace,
where there are
free and paid images
that you can download for
your machine specifically.
So you can see
there 46 quick start
ones that are default ones.
These 10,000 are images that
have been published by all sorts
of companies.
So you can see
OpenVPN has an image.
Palo Alto Networks has an image.
And these, you can just
select and download.
And you obviously
know why you would
need to install one of
these, if you're specifically
selecting one of these.
But it's all to say there's
a lot of different options,
pre-installed software.
There are also
community ones that
are published by basically
anyone, though notice
that they have less scrutiny.
So you would have to
ensure for yourself, aside
from the fact that some of
these say verified provider.
But if you download
some other random one,
I would just make sure you trust
the publisher of the image.
But for us, it's way easier.
Again, like I said,
we're going to go Ubuntu.
We're going to come in here.
And I'm just going
to pick 22.04.
22.04 and 24.04, both
should be roughly the same.
There may be slight differences
in what I do in between those,
but I will try to
exclusively stay on 22.04.
That is one of the long-term
stable versions of it
and should be stable throughout
at least this course.
If it's not supported
anymore in the free tier,
you won't see this here.
So for example, in previous
semesters, I used to use 22.04.
Eventually, it'll get
outdated as well, too.
And then they'll push it back
and not necessarily offer it
as a free tier.
Again, any flavor of
Ubuntu 2022, '24, '26,
whatever the next long-term
stable version you run into
will functionally be the
same with just the slightest
of differences.
And you're welcome
to always talk
to me if you run into an
error and you're like,
I think this might be an
operating system issue
that I can help you debug.
So selected 22.04.
We won't worry about the
architecture right now.
This isn't necessarily
useful for what
we're doing in this
course, but it's
cool to notice that we can
choose different silicon
architectures for this.
So x86 and Arm being two of the
largest competing architectures.
Again, I'm getting into
stuff that is way outside
the scope of this course.
So I apologize.
But it's just to say, if
you need to do development
on, for example, an
Arm-based architecture,
like, for example, new MacBooks
or the M1, M2, M3 chips,
those are all Arm-based
architectures,
then you can choose to do that.
So you can see here the
more important detail
is I can basically
simulate or replicate
a bunch of different
types of computers.
So no matter what I'm
doing, I can probably
find some way to build
a computer like that
just by selecting these
options, as opposed
to having to physically
buy the hardware
and set it up in my
house and all that stuff.
So we'll go 64-bit, x86.
That's all the defaults.
Then we can jump on to
the instance type here.
So the instance
type is our choice
of what physical hardware
is supporting the computer.
So we've talked
about this before.
Again, there's T2 or there's
the T series of instances.
There's the C's, the
R's, and F, G. There's
all sorts of different letters.
You can click here
and scroll through.
I mean, you can see how small
this little scrolly bar is here,
all sorts of different ones.
And they have
different purposes.
So like, for example, I think
the A, the M, and the T,
and you can identify that
by the initial letter, that
is any broad or general
purpose instance type.
You have the C series.
So we saw some right
here the C5s, the C4s.
These are more high-performance
computers, like research tasks,
researcher, or scientific tasks.
There are some
in-memory database.
So there's ones that are
designed or optimized
for database work.
So like the R series.
I think it's like R4.
Yeah, a note up here.
R4, R5, X1, Z1.
These are all better
for our database systems
dash machine-learning instances.
I tend to use the G4D series
a lot for an extra large
because these come
with GPUs on board.
All sorts of
different use cases.
And you can also see they
list the prizes here.
So for example, the t2.micro,
which is free tier eligible--
note that again.
Free tier eligible means we
can run this at the free tier.
And again, if you don't
remember from previous videos,
the free tier for EC2
instances, I believe,
is 750 hours a month of a
t2 or t3.micro instances.
And that is for your first 12
months of having an account.
If you were outside of your
initial 12 months, then
that will be charged
at basically the rate
you can see here.
So for example, if you're
outside of that free tier,
[INAUDIBLE] beyond 12 months or
you haven't set up a new account
recently, then you will be
charged basically $0.01 per hour
for usage of this.
Nothing we do in
this class needs
to stay live really
for any amount
of time outside of the
time you're working on it.
So you're always
welcome to if there's
an assignment you need
to turn in and it's like,
hey, well, I'm asking you to do
something on your EC2 instance.
You can always screenshot it.
Show me what the
output looks like.
And it'll be clear
on each assignment.
And then you can just terminate
the instance after that.
So I won't ever expect
you to just leave
an instance live and
charge yourself for that.
That wouldn't be fair.
You just basically
waiting on me to grade.
So screenshot and send
it to me if you ever
have issues with that.
Then moving on.
We have-- so again,
like I said, we
need to consider the
pricing, then also
the number of CPUs
and the memory size.
So that can vary
based off of, again,
how intensive the
processing task
is, how much memory is needed.
We talked about that a
little in previous lectures.
But again, for our
case, we don't need
to worry about it too much.
We can use a t2.micro.
Just to show, though,
price comparisons.
If I were to step up
and use the g4dn 16 xl,
for example, that's
up to $5 an hour.
So it can get very pricey.
Be very intentional and clear in
choosing the smallest instance
necessary for your task.
Again, I'll oftentimes select a
really, really small instance.
And then just spin up a bigger
one the second I need it.
And then shut it off the
second I don't need it anymore.
And again, also, you can see a
slight price increase associated
with Windows versus Linux.
It doesn't seem like
much, only $0.05,
but that's a pretty significant
percentage increase.
If I have 100, 200,
employees using these EC2
instances each
day, all day, you'd
probably want to minimize
that as much as possible.
So we'll just select
for now the t2.micro.
So now that we've selected
the t2.micro instance,
we're feeling good about that.
That all makes sense.
We're at the free tier.
We can see both here and here.
Moving on, we get
to the key pair.
So with the key pair--
with this basically
says is now we
want to be able to
connect to our instance
from our local machine.
Whenever I say local, I mean
your computer physically
sitting in front of you.
Remote is going to be my
cloud computer, right?
My computer that-- my EC2
instance that I have spun up.
So I want to securely
connect from local to remote.
And the reason I want to have
this kind of secure connection
is I don't want to allow
somebody or anybody else
in the world to
be able to access
this computer,
this EC2 instance.
This could have private
or proprietary information
on there.
So I need to have
some way to keep
that secure from outside
users or any user-intercepting
information there.
So the way that's done or most
commonly done is via key pairs.
A key pair is basically a
private key and a public key.
And we're going to have a whole
lecture talking about this.
So don't worry, it doesn't
have to make sense now.
But basically, imagine a
password, a private password
and a public password.
The public password,
anybody could see it.
I mean, we still try
to keep it private.
But conceivably,
anybody could see it,
and they can't make
any sense of it.
But the important
thing is, the only way
to confirm that you're allowed
to connect to this instance
is that the public
password basically
has an unlocking password.
This private password comes
in and says, OK, well, now I
put these two together.
Now, all of a sudden,
I know that this
is a secure connection.
This is the only password,
the only private password that
works with this public one.
So anybody can see
this public one.
We come in with our
private password.
And all of a sudden, it
says, oh, actually, this
is a trusted entity.
So it's really
important that when
you have this secure
key pair or you
create this key pairs is
that you keep track of these,
that they're going to be
kept secure on your device
or separate from
any other users.
Once you have created one
as well, you can reuse it.
You don't have to create
a new one each time,
but you will need to
keep that file on hand.
So the way you create one
is, obviously, just click
this Create New Key Pair.
I come in here and I'll
say, OK, well, maybe
this is Sharad's
computer, right?
I'm saying, OK, this is-- and
I'm calling it this so that I
know--
OK, well, specifically,
maybe Sharad's MacBook Pro.
This is his computer.
He knows that it's
only for this computer,
and this specific file
is on this computer.
There are different types,
and this is based off
the type of encryption used.
Again, we'll talk about
that in another lecture.
For now, we'll stick with RSA,
and we'll also stick with PEM.
PEM is-- and this is just the
file type of the private key.
For the context of
what we're doing,
PEM should be perfectly fine.
I believe it's going to be more
portable, or a better statement,
more widely usable.
Certain operating systems can't
work with PPK files, vice versa.
So PEM should work for now, but
we'll just make note of that.
So we'll create a
key pair, and you'll
notice immediately
it downloaded a file.
It's going to be called .pem.
You can physically open it up
and look at this as well, too.
So obviously, I
wouldn't ask you to do
this with your own key pair.
Don't share this with anybody.
But if you want to see
what it looks like,
I just need to have a text
editor that can read this.
Yeah, here we go.
We'll use this.
So if you want to see
what this looks like--
I'm showing this
only because I'm
going to delete this
immediately after using it
so you won't be able to
use my information here.
But this is what it looks like.
As you can see, it's just
a long alphanumeric string.
It's not comprehensible
to what we're doing,
but this is the private key.
So this is a file that I have to
physically keep on my computer
to be able to connect
to any machine that
has the public key, the
associated public key,
of this private key pair.
So we've created this.
It's downloaded to
my Downloads folder.
Then when I launch
this instance,
this will also be put
onto that new instance.
So again, we can have
that secure handshake
between the two.
So that physically downloads
the file to my computer.
If it didn't download a file
to your computer, try again.
Make sure it downloads
it appropriately.
And again, in the future, I
don't have to necessarily create
a new one.
I can just say,
OK, let's come here
and select Sharad's
MacBook Pro, or you
can see there's a
bunch of past ones
that we have in
there as well, too.
There's nothing secret about
the name of the key pair itself.
The only important
thing to keep private
is that private key file.
If somebody gets
access to that, they
can access your remote instance.
So keep that in mind, assuming
that I always have the IP
address and other stuff.
We got the key pair set up.
Then coming in here, we
have the network settings.
For what we're
doing here, we don't
have to worry about the
actual network we're using.
Though, conceivably,
you can do some things
like leveraging
virtual private clouds,
where we basically create
an isolated portion
of the cloud for maybe our
organization or something
like that.
But for what we're doing, we
won't worry about those pieces.
The most important part for us
is actually right down here,
when we get to the
security group.
This basically says or
establishes what sort of traffic
is allowed in and
out of the instance.
This may be not something we--
or this might not be something
you often think about.
But basically, when we are
making a connection, when
I'm going to a
website, that website
has an IP address, a unique
address associated with it.
It'll look like this.
It'll be some number dot, some
number dot, some number dot,
some number,
something like that.
To make that
connection, we basically
have to use our computer
on our home network.
We have to allow our--
home internet network has
to allow traffic to go
out from our computer,
out of our home, to whatever
the remote server is.
That remote server has to allow
any IP address to come into it,
retrieve information,
and then it
has to also allow the
information to go back out.
And then our home network
has to allow information
to come back into, but
very specific Information
we requested.
This sort of handoff
happens behind the scenes
so quickly and completely,
imperceptibly to us.
But now that we're
setting this up,
we want to have fine-tuned
control over this
so we can allow only certain
information in and out.
It's another layer of security
to basically say, well--
for example, if I don't
check these two boxes,
allow HTTPS traffic
and allow HTTP traffic.
Then if somebody tries to come
to my IP address via a website
approach using HTTP, it just
won't allow it in and be
like, well, that's not allowed.
I only allow things that are
coming in as SSH traffic, which
is how we're actually going
to connect to this instance.
So this is another kind of layer
of security we can add on to it.
Similar to the key pair,
I can select existing ones
once I've created them.
So I can create a very
specific one, the name,
and say like, hey, this
is all of my rules in it.
And we'll use these rules
throughout the semester
so you'll see what
I mean by that.
But for now, we're only going
to allow SSH traffic in.
And specifically, we're going
to allow it from anywhere.
What that means is it
says, OK, well-- so SSH
is a secure shell protocol.
And it says, I'm
allowing you to--
you'll see, we'll do
it from the terminal
or from the command line.
And we'll say, I'm allowing
you to use this protocol
to connect to this EC2 instance.
And I'm allowing you to do
that from any IP address.
That is technically not the
most secure way to do it.
If I wanted to be very secure,
I could say, well, actually,
I'm going to only allow SSH
traffic from my home IP address.
That way, if somebody tries
to connect to my EC2 instance,
even if they have my private key
pair, unless they're on my home
network, they can't get in.
They can't connect to it.
So if I'm a company or an
organization, what I might do
is I might say, OK, well,
this range of IP addresses
is associated with our office.
If you're not within our office
or not VPN into our office,
you cannot access this network,
or you cannot access this EC2
instance.
So that is one way to create
another layer of security
around your EC2 instance here.
Also, if I'm ever using
terms that don't make sense,
please shoot me a message.
I'm trying to avoid
jargon, but I inevitably
end up using jargon.
I realize that, as I just
said that VPN, Virtual Private
Network, not necessarily
for right now,
but it's just another
thing to note.
So we're going to allow
SSH traffic from anywhere
to just keep it simple.
We're not doing anything
sensitive on these EC2 instances
anyway.
So it's not a big deal.
Configuring storage.
So this is basically how much
EBS storage we want to do.
And we'll have a whole
section on storage.
I apologize.
I keep saying it's going to be
like stuff that's coming up.
But basically, think of this
like a external hard drive
that you're plugging
into the computer, right?
You machine, it has some default
amount of storage or memory
on it.
And you're like, well, I want
to have an external hard drive
that I can just plug into it.
And the reason I say it's
an external hard drive
is I can technically
swap these EBS volumes.
It's what we'll call them, these
Elastic Block Storage volumes.
It's just a brand name
for what AWS calls them.
I can attach them to
different computers.
So I can create this
external hard drive
for this EC2 instance.
I can terminate
this EC2 instance
but keep my EBS volume alive,
and plug it into a new computer.
So I can plug it into
a new EC2 instance,
if I need to use it again.
It is important to note
that these are charged.
So you will pay for EBS volumes.
So when you terminate
the instance,
if you've created it in this
way where you create the EBS
storage, the volume with
creating the EC2 instance,
it'll give you the option
to just delete both of them
right away.
But if you create it
separately and just delete
the EC2 instance, it
might not necessarily
delete that EBS volume.
So that can still accrue cost.
So it's worth keeping in mind.
Also, if you stop your
EC2 instance, which
we'll see that that's an option
to stop the EC2 instance,
that does not stop
your EBS volume.
You will be charged for that.
So you won't be paying for your
EC2 instance while it's stopped,
but you will pay
for your EBS volume.
The pricing on these,
I believe, right now--
don't quote me.
Let's see.
EBS volume pricing.
I believe it's like $0.30,
like $0.30 a gigabyte.
GP2.
I think we're looking
at a GP2 volume.
Yeah, GP2.
Typically, at $0.10
per gigabyte month.
So for each gigabyte you
have live for a month,
you will be charged $0.10
per those gigabytes.
So for example here, if we left
this one live-- now granted
this is free-tier eligible.
So if you're still within
your first 12 months,
you get up to 30
gigs of EBS storage
for free, specifically for GP2
and GP3 instance type or volume
types.
So if you're still
in the free tier,
this won't cost you
as long as you're not
exceeding 30 gigabytes across
all of your EBS volumes.
But 8 gig is perfectly fine
for what we're doing here.
That's also the minimum.
So that's why it's set there.
But be mindful of that.
So if you were outside
of the free tier,
then if you left this one
live for a whole month,
this would cost you $0.80.
So not a big deal here.
But if I make that 80 gigabytes,
we're up to 80 times that $0.10
or up to $8 now for that month.
And a simple extra number
could make that $80.
So you can see, it's
really important
to be mindful of what
you're putting in there
and keeping track of that.
So either way, 8 gigabytes,
that's the default.
We need to have an EBS
volume attached anyway.
So we'll leave that.
And right now, we won't leverage
any of these advanced details.
But later on, we'll
come back and talk
about these IAM instance
profiles and what IAM means.
For now, don't
worry about these.
If you're curious,
there are some things
like auto recovery or shutdown
behavior, for example.
So if I select Shutdown for
this EC2 instance-- sorry,
there's just too many
vocabulary words.
If I select Shutdown
for this EC2 instance,
do I want that to mean
I stop the EC2 instance,
or do I want that to
mean I terminate it?
Remember stopping
just means it's
kind of hanging in the
balance, but I still
keep everything live, if I
need to spin it back up again.
Terminate means I just
delete it entirely.
Termination protection.
If, for example, you're
working with a team or a larger
group that shares
an AWS account,
you can turn on
Termination Protection,
such that if somebody goes
to terminate your instance,
maybe they just
select, OK, terminate
all instances, anything that
has termination protection
will not get terminated.
And basically, it'll
flag it and say, hey,
if you want to terminate this,
you have to intentionally choose
to click on this, go
into the instance,
shut down Termination
Protection,
and then you can do that.
It's meant to add, basically,
this extra step, such
that you don't accidentally
delete important instances.
So if that's necessary, it's
certainly something you can use.
Similar thing with
Stop Protection
and all that good stuff.
So most of these details
are not important for what
we're doing right now, but
just know they're here as well.
So a quick summary on all this.
We name our instance.
We select our operating system.
Here, I chose Ubuntu.
And our image, which here
was just Ubuntu 22.04.
This is at the free tier.
I select my instance type.
So what type of computer it is?
In this case, it's
just a t2.micro.
So it has one virtual CPU
and one gigabyte of RAM.
This is not, again, EBS volume.
This is RAM.
This is that working memory
I select or I
created a key pair,
and I'm using that key pair.
That key pair is downloaded
onto my computer.
I'm creating my security
group that allows
SSH traffic, configure storage.
And now I'm going to go ahead
and click Launch Instance.
And this may take a few
seconds to a few minutes.
So there's no rush if it's
not launched right away.
Notice this just
says that initiated
the launch of the instance.
If you click this little
alphanumeric string here,
it'll bring you to
the dashboard page
that shows the status
of this EC2 instance.
So you can see it's
our test server,
and it's in this instance
state of pending.
I'll click this
instance ID again,
which brings us to another page.
It kind of shows a
little bit more detail
that'll be important
for us to use later on.
For example, it gives us
the public IP address.
This is physically
the website, the--
I don't call it
the website so much
as the address of this machine.
So if you're looking for where
this machine is physically
located at on the internet, it
is located at 34.221.223.39.
That is the home address
of that computer, right?
It's not meaningful
to us, but it
is meaningful as we're
routing internet traffic,
as we're trying to
move through there
and find where
this is located at.
And specifically, that
is the public one.
So that is available
or that is what
some external computer
would have to use
to connect to this machine.
Later on, as we start
to build websites,
we'll learn how we can use this
home address to basically say,
OK, I want to go
to the website that
happens to be hosted by this
EC2 instance at this public IP
address.
So that's what giving us there.
Again, you have your
instance state right here.
So you can see that it's
pending still to launch.
And then down here, we
have a bunch of details.
Most importantly and the thing
we'll come back to quite a bit
this semester is,
again, the security.
So this was our security group
that allowed SSH traffic.
And you can see
right here this rule
that says, we allow
inbound traffic--
so it's an inbound rule--
through port 22 from anywhere.
Port 22 basically just means
that you can think about it
like a shipping port, right?
It is saying, hey, we expect
that traffic will be coming in
through this specific port.
So we open this port up.
We say, ships can
come in here, traffic
can come in through this port.
But anything else, if they try
to hit port 33, port 77, or port
any number, that's not open.
There's no port open to this.
So always keep that
in mind that that'll
specify what is allowed in.
Sometimes you run
into and you'll
see errors later on that
say, hey, you can't access,
or there's no response
from the EC2 instance
or from this website.
And that might be because
there's no port open.
So I would double check that
the port you're trying to access
is set as allowing
inbound traffic
from anywhere or at least
from your IP address.
Port 22 is a reserved
or a special one
that is for SSH traffic,
the secure shell
traffic, which we're going
to use to connect to it.
But again, there's nothing
unique about these numbers
outside of them being
standard practice for what
that port means.
Similarly, you can see
there's outbound rules.
This says that we
allow traffic out
from any port to
any destination.
So right, it's going
the other direction now.
So it says, OK, we
allow only traffic
in from this specific place,
but we allow traffic out
from any location.
So those are some details there.
Let's see if we're in a
state where it's created.
Yep, and you can
see it's running.
So if it's not showing up there,
you can just click Refresh.
It doesn't take that long
to create these machines.
So if it's hanging
forever, you can always
just try shutting it down
and starting it back up.
But now that it's created,
we're going to click Connect.
And this will bring
us to this page.
We have a couple different
options to connect.
The two that we're going
to use or could use
are either this EC2 Instance
Connect or SSH Client.
EC2 Instance Connect,
it's probably
the easiest way to do it.
You literally just click
Connect and it'll bring us up
to the terminal page.
But I'll say it's
the most finicky.
I've had mixed results
with using this.
So I would not encourage
this, though note
that this is an option.
What I'm going to primarily
focus on this most
or primarily do is
connect through SSH.
So this is something
that is and this
is the one thing that is
going to be operating-system
specific this semester.
So if you're on a
Mac, you're going
to use what's called terminal.
So if you just pull up
your spotlight search,
you hit Command and
Spacebar and type terminal.
You can hit Enter
and bring that up.
If you're on a Windows machine,
hit Windows-S to search
and then start
typing PowerShell.
It'll be called
PowerShell like that.
All Windows machines should
have PowerShell on them.
It looks very similar to this.
It has slightly
different commands.
So this will be the one thing
that's slightly different.
If you have issues,
come talk to me,
but I'll try to explain
them both right now.
I just, obviously, only
have a Mac up right now.
So I can only show
that here visibly.
But again, like I said, they
both take roughly the same shape
in what they do.
And this is basically it, right?
It is a text box or kind of
a text box-looking thing.
It should say something
about your computer,
maybe what type
of computer it is.
Something like that right here.
This part to the left of this
percent sign-- or I forget,
on Windows, it might
be dollar sign.
But basically, this part you
can type into is what matters.
Everything else is just telling
me something about my machine.
The terminal is really
nice or the command prompt
or PowerShell, whatever
you want to call it,
depending on your
machine, because it
allows us to send
commands to the computer.
This is the oldest way that
computers used to operate.
It's just one command after
another saying, do this, do
this, do this.
Now we abstract that
away with user interface,
where we click buttons.
But behind the scenes,
a lot of times,
it's still doing something
very similar to this,
where it's just sending
off a single command
with different arguments.
And so we're going to use
this to connect to our machine
now, to connect to
this remote machine.
So the first thing we're
going to have to do
is change to the
directory, where
we have our key pair located.
Remember, we have
that secure key pair.
So to change
directory and this is
going to be the
same on both of them
is you would do
cd and then Space.
And then I would typically
start typing Downloads.
And rather than typing it
all out, easiest thing to do
is just to hit Tab, and your
computer will auto complete it
with the appropriate format.
I think on Windows,
it's slightly different.
It'll do dot slash download
or something like that.
Just start typing Downloads,
hit Tab, and then hit Enter.
And it should bring you
to your Downloads folder.
If you have trouble with that,
you can certainly google it.
I would just search how
to change the directory
to your Downloads folder from
PowerShell or from the terminal,
but make sure you specify
what your operating system is
for that.
Or again, come talk to me, and
we can debug really, really
quickly.
But now that we're in
our Downloads folder,
this is physically
the same as opening up
your File Explorer
or your finder,
clicking on your
Downloads folder
and just sitting right
there in that folder.
We'll have a whole
separate lecture
next that talks about
all these commands,
but this is just to get us
connected to the machine.
Now, if you're on
a Mac, then you
need to run this next command
that shows up right here.
So you see how it
said open SSH client?
We did that.
Locate your private key file.
It's located in my
Downloads folder.
Yours should be there, too.
Or if moved it somewhere else,
you can go to that location.
Then I need to run this command.
Now, again, I have not
had to do this on Windows.
And actually, I don't believe
the ch mod command works
on Windows.
So don't worry about this one.
But if you're on a Mac, make
sure you do run this one.
Again, like I said,
it's the one thing
that's slightly different
between the two.
So we'll paste that,
and I'll hit Enter.
It doesn't say anything,
and that's good.
That means it worked.
Then now we can connect to our
instance using its public DNS.
I don't know why they show it
like this because, actually,
all you need to do is copy this
thing that's under example.
SSH -i, notice we're using
our special key pair.
Yours is going to be different.
And then this is the unique
public address for your machine.
So you need to copy
it from this page
because yours is not going to
be the same as mine right here.
So we copy this.
Click that little
button to copy it,
then come back to our terminal
or our PowerShell, whatever.
And again, if you're
on Windows, you
would just copy
this the same way.
Paste it and hit Enter.
It'll oftentimes ask you if you
want to continue connecting.
You type yes.
Hit Enter.
And then boom, we're into it.
So now you can see, it's
this as ubuntu@ip dash--
whatever the private IP
address was for this.
This will match what shows
up on your instance page.
And this means that I am now
connected to this computer.
It's a remote computer.
It's not located here
anywhere near me.
This is in some data center in
the US West 2 region, somewhere
near Oregon-ish, maybe.
So we've connected to a
remote computer successfully.
This we can use to do pretty
much anything we want now.
Send all sorts of commands,
run all sorts of software,
and we're going to do
it all from this window.
So you're going to get
very, very comfortable
with the terminal window now.
And the cool thing
is, too, again,
whether you're on
Mac, PC, Linux,
whatever, we're all going
to see the exact same window
at this point because
now this is actually
running on an Ubuntu machine.
I am not running
this on my computer.
This is on that separate one.
So that's the real power
of what we're doing here
is we have connections
now to remote computers.
Final thing, how to shut it
down, terminate all this stuff.
If you want to, you can type
exit and just click Exit.
And it'll bring you
back to your machine.
Notice now I'm back at
Sharad's MacBook Pro.
If you close it, it'll
just close fine as well.
If I want to reconnect
to it, all I have to do
is tap up on the arrow
key, and it'll take me back
to that previous command.
And I can hit Enter.
And I can reconnect
to it as well.
So I can keep going in
and out of it just fine.
It is a computer now
that I have access to.
If, for example, you did
not set that security group
or we had an issue setting
that security group,
like we talked about before
with the port range, then
it wouldn't have
let us do that task.
We had to go in through SSH,
which is assumed to be port 22.
So again, if you had issues,
double check that this got
added as a security rule.
If not, just recreate
it and add that back.
So now that we're back
here at our instance page,
the last step, like I
said, is to terminate it
when you're done using it.
The way I would operate this
entire class is, do the task,
work through this in class, or
as you're watching these videos,
work on the assignment.
Once you're done with
it, though, terminate it.
Even if you're on the
free tier, terminate it.
It's just good practice.
If you are going
to need it later
or you want to keep building
on it, that's perfectly fine.
Just be mindful
of, if you're still
falling within that free tier
or if you're exceeding it.
But if you want to delete
it, click Instance State
and then we're going to go down
to terminate or delete instance.
It's going to say, on
an EBS-backed instance,
the default action is
for the root EBS volume
to be deleted when the
instance is terminated.
Storage on any local
drives will be lost.
That's good.
That's saying,
hey, just you know,
you had an EBS volume
attached to this.
If you delete this, it's
going to delete that EBS
volume as well, meaning that we
won't be charged for it anymore.
And since we're not
using anything on that,
that's perfectly fine.
Notice we didn't have
termination protection
that was disabled.
So all we've got to
click is Terminate.
And then it's initiating
the termination.
It'll go into a
shutting-down state.
And then pretty soon, if we come
back to this instances page,
you'll see-- for example, this
one just says, shutting down.
But one that I was working
on earlier to test this out
says, terminated, because I
terminated that one already.
And after a couple hours or
so, I forget how long it takes.
It'll just not even
show up on here at all.
So you won't even have any
trace that this was ever
created as an instance.
One other thing to be
mindful of with this
is, if you, for
example, are constantly
switching your regions, the EC2
instances are region specific.
So notice here that I have
a few instances there.
This is an organization one.
So that's why there's a
bunch of different ones.
If I switch over to
Northern California,
I have an entirely
different 148 instances
that are listed right here.
So it's an entirely
different set of instances.
And if I switch to
Northern Virginia,
it's going to be an entirely
different set of instances.
So just be aware
that it's very easy
to create an instance in Oregon
and then not realize next time
that you create it in
a different region.
And then realize the
next time you create it
in different region.
And all of a sudden, you have a
bunch of different EC2 instances
scattered around.
And again, at the
free tier, you only
have 750 hours of EC2 instances
of t2 or t3.micro instance
types per month.
And that's cumulative across
all the different instances.
So if I have 750
instances live, then I
got one hour on each of those
before I start getting charged.
So again, just be
mindful of that.
So with that, I'll stop here.
That's plenty of information.
Hopefully, you can come
back through, rewatch this,
redo this process.
There will be an
assignment to just show
that you have been able
to connect to this.
So you'll see that on
Canvas as well, too.
But it's important that
you feel very comfortable
with this process.
We are going to do this over
and over and over again.
And in all honesty,
if you come to me
and you say, hey, there
was an error with this,
or I can't seem to
connect to my instance,
the first thing I'm
going to say is, have you
tried just terminating it
and creating a new one?
Because it'll oftentimes
be way faster than trying
to debug an error.
So get very comfortable
with that workflow.
Just come in here
and click Launch
an Instance, Name, Image,
OS, Key Pair, Instance Type,
Network Settings,
Connect, Launch Instance.
So get used to that process.
So we're going to
leave it at that.
And then come back
next time and start
talking about how we can
actually use or leverage
these EC2 instances.
So thanks.